as more americans are choosing to fly  again we're seeing long lines at tsa  checkpoints you may have noticed already  a recent agency memo shows the tsa can't  really keep up with demand  225 u.s airports now understaffed  some of our nation's busiest airports in  washington dc in boston  they're short as many as a hundred tsa  officers while the tsa is trying to  staff up  critics think they're gonna fall short  so there's a long  process in uh getting an employee ready  to clean passengers  for their safety so why do you think the  tsa  won't hit its benchmark uh right now  it's not too many people applying for  this job maybe because of the pay  you know they look at other federal  agencies and compared to paid  tsa officials say though they are ready  to meet the rise in travel demands and  have  since offered incentives for new hires